one
your life chat good evening and welcome
to this oversight and scrutiny committee
meeting on Tuesday the 1st of August
2023.
my name is councilor Simon Morgan and I
am the chairperson of this committee
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you're giving
your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I'll
then invite you at the appropriate time
could I ask members to avoid approaching
the top tables this could create
interference with the cameras and live
stream
please note the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can I ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible before
proceeding all I just wanted to say I'm
sure I speak for cancer Spencer List
that we're all very much looking forward
to working together with you all going
forward for the municipal year I'm
reminded of the great phrase quiz
custodiet it shows custodies which I'm
sure councilor Lagan will be able to
inform you means who looks after those
people who are supposed to be looking
after other people and that is what this
committee is here for uh to keep a
watching brief uh and to make sure that
people are held to account anyway
without further Ado uh moving on to item
two apologies for absence Sean do we
have any apologies
we have apologies from councilor Hughes
thank you Jeff thank you okay uh moving
on to item three minutes of the last
meeting it is remember recommended that
the minutes of the meeting held on the
28th of March 2023 which uh you should
have had to find within your papers are
approved as a true and accurate record
so I move do I have a second
cancel tonight thanks
do I take that as taken person
okay moving on to item four Declarations
of interest it's important to disclose
the existence and nature of any
disclosable peculiary interests other
registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph nine and appendix B
of the code of conduct for members
uh members robotics it also required to
suppose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the knees arise
through the meeting is there any
discouragement
right
in which case uh moving on to item five
uh which is an update on the scrutiny
work plan
and perhaps Mr Jennings could you lead
us into that
thank you chairman
um yes the purpose of this report is
really to
um set the scene really for for the new
committee and its work over coming weeks
and months
and the main body of that report
um picks up from what was reported to
the council in May at the statutory
annual meeting as this committee is
required to do uh to provide an annual
report
so it picks up on all those items
um that still sit currently on the
scrutiny work plan to be picked up by
this committee and its working group
going forward
um
it states the origins and it states that
the general terms and remit of what's
being looked into and provides an update
as to where the matter actually sits at
this point ready to be picked up
um I think it's worth mentioning
um
at this point there are two significant
items that are very much in the course
of
um
work and work therefore to be developed
further the first one is called planning
decision making and
the committee has already made
recommendations to council which have
been accepted and have been
implemented but there is more to do as
is highlighted here
and there may well be added other things
added by members as they they work this
item through
um it is a very wide-ranging subject
and the ultimate thought was that out of
this the committee would come up with
and commend to the council a new
formed of a better phrase protocol on
decision making relating to planning
which could become a component of the
Constitution
so
that is that item the the second item is
is another
meaty item really it's planning
enforcement performance and processes
this began with
um quite an extensive request for
information
and it's clear that associated with work
going on within the planning directorate
restructuring and looking in detail at
dealing with historic problems
associated with enforcement particularly
a backlog of items the processes
attached to that
now that structures are being put in
place resources are being
clarified to to put to enforcement no
doubt the committee will wish to look
for Progress that is being made in
relation to Performance and I've added a
note
in the third column there that um
since the last since the annual report
to Council in mail or at least the last
time this committee looked at it more
recent internal performance data
indicated that further progress in the
closing of cases with the number of open
cases at the beginning of the year
having been halved by mid-june yeah
um thank you Mr Jennings we are I think
uh joined by an altoff Shoreland who I
think and you're able to talk to us a
bit more about the enforcement matters
how we're doing
so at the moment we've got about
391 Active cases
five appeals we're doing five appeals at
the moment so that where where we closed
cases and we've served this year nine
enforcement notices the knock-on effect
of that is we will then have more
appeals to deal with in the tea so about
five of one of which is going to a
public inquiry so we serve nine
enforcement registers
we're just about to serve another one
and one breach of condition notice we've
closed 459 cases since the beginning of
the year
um and now
be out back Beyond 2020 so inclusive of
2020 back to 2011. we've got 157 cases
still open so we've got and we've had 98
in this year so it's not not too bad
this year so far
um we've introduced our mapping app so
that members can self-serve the
information which seems to be working
quite well actually because
the interim not that we don't love
interacting with you but the interaction
with members how to reduce significantly
and and ever have checked and members
are using themselves so back so it must
it must be working
we've introduced a quicker way to deal
with region condition notices because we
used to have to we used to go through
this enormous memo thing that we talked
about and you'd have to write a report
that would take hours and then you don't
really have to do that there's no legal
obligation to do it you can't appeal
against a Bridge condition notice so
we've issued a much we've
developed a much quicker way of serving
those notices
um
we've also carried out some team
training now on expediency and how to
write an appointment notice we now have
a half an hour meeting I think every
morning four days a week to catch up
with the team so we're learning as a
team every day basically and it's um it
does seem to be going quite well I have
to say but we have reached a plateau
because the cases we've got in left in
the main are the more complex ones
thank you
um before we move on to the rest of this
report I was wondering if members any
questions that they want to put yes
thanks
um
regard to the stuff
the stuff I know we spoke about Staffing
resource before and whether or not
um we would be looking going forward at
the introduction of a compliance officer
and how the Staffing is working out and
whether it's where you need it to be
because especially as you're talking
about having plateaued now the the
progress that was being made
um I suppose it's just looking you know
how how are you with Staffing and and
how is that
um impacting progress
well we're going to when we're going
through the study restaurants so we've
done phase one so the host of service
are in place so the head of the head of
service in terms of planning enforcement
has not been resolved yet so I'm still
I'm still there
managing the team
for the moment
we are going to have a phase two
restructure which I hope is going to be
introduced to staff
mid month and I can't I can't talk about
it because it has the staff don't know
about it yet okay all I can say is
if we can introduce what I would like us
to introduce I will be very pleased
I think it will help us enormously it's
fine so and I can't really say
ing but it's confidential at the moment
um if I come back at the next meeting
and it's been able to starve then we can
we can talk about it but I think I think
if everything goes according to plan I
think that we will be quite happy about
it
thank you it's just because we'd spoken
about that at the last meeting so it was
just a follow-on from that and the other
thing that we um spoke about the last
meeting was a review of our enforcement
policy in terms of prioritizing certain
um
jobs or you know things Enforcement
cases that come forward and Inter in
terms of whether or not they're really
urgent so if it's a a TPO or a historic
building or something like that and I
just wondered if there was any progress
on reviewing the enforcement policy and
where we are with that
no
[Music]
I wanted the red structure to be sorted
out first because I don't I'm not 100
sure if it's going to be me as the head
of surface but when I get to that point
I did want members involvement in that
what I will say is because we have a
half an hour meeting every morning four
days a week now I think it means that we
we hit the more things like tpos
and listed buildings we hit those site
visits much quicker because we're
talking about them every morning and
it'll say right if it's going out on
site oh you can you go and do this and I
think that's working quite well but I
still would want to build that into
a more safe I think I think and just
look at the policy in the round to make
sure it is doing what it should be doing
and telling people how we operate I mean
you know we we need things like um
a ripper policy how we're going to deal
with the regulation of investigatory
Powers Act you know those sort of things
are not not in place and I think they
should be in place so as soon as we get
the bridge crutch sorted out I think you
know I think yes I would like help to do
that piece of work
councilor Morley
thank you chair
um yes I was just wondering with
how do you see the ratios or the trend
if with more planning
is there more enforcement to do or is
are you now you're sort of nipping it in
the bud a bit do you find that you're
keeping on top of it a little bit has it
sort of stayed fairly stable the trend
of
planning being granted and then
enforcements having to be
looked at
visit oh I think we've reached unless we
sort of change our structure slightly I
think we probably reached a point where
as cases come in cases are being
resolved so
I don't think we'll see a massive a
massive drop again unless we we alter
the structure a little bit and we're not
talking about radical anything radical
just tweaking really
thank you any other
I understand if you want to go on just
finish the other items
yes chairman I I think the rest of the
report
um
takes care of itself the the other items
are dependent on information coming
forward and all of these items will be
picked up by the working group in due
course for more detailed consideration
and report back to the committee
um
the cyber security update is is there
that that is dependent on information
and outcomes and recommendations from
two internal audit reports on the
subject
um that that will be largely a matter
for members to receive assurance and be
assured that all the necessary actions
and recommendations have been followed
um and the last item safeguarding of
children and vulnerable adults corporate
risk update
um that has been earmarked for a report
back to the committee before the end of
September but there again
um that will be a matter for report to
the working group and as an interim
which will fit within that time scale so
subject to that chairman it's it's
really at this stage for the for the
committee to note they will be dealing
with these subjects
in more detail in the days and weeks and
months to come has anyone anything they
want to question Mr Jennings about which
case I propose that we just proceed with
the recommendations
okay uh moving on to agenda item six the
working group of the overview and
scrutiny committee
um Council Spencer can you introduce
this for us
okay so as you can see with the report
before you
um
the previous Arrangement was that
um we had we we had four members of the
committee form the working group The
working group would meet online during
the day
um and my experience of that working
group well we worked very very hard was
that it was very variable how many
people we actually got onto the meetings
at any one given time and then we'd come
back to committee and one of the
problems that I identified was that
people then in the committee we spent
more time talking about
what we'd found as the you know as the
working group and what we've done than
perhaps resolving the issue itself and
making the recommendations to move
forward
um so
um myself and the chairman have spoken
about this and were of the opinion that
we would like to see all members of the
committee invited to be part of the
working group as we don't have a huge
committee and it is only the size of a
lot of working groups and obviously you
know not everybody may be able to attend
all the time but the the openness of it
would then be there for members to take
part and I also felt that we would have
um more input from people in different
perspectives
um on things going forward so you know
it'd be quite open and transparent and
we could also look at and it's actually
something that we were speaking about
this afternoon having people from
um perhaps even external Partners come
in and talk to the committee and as we
do when we have the crime and disorder
panel and say for example with regard to
health and education and so we could
actually
open up our our work quite a lot more
and I think working quite a productive
way and have hybrid meetings potentially
for the working group where possible as
well so um that's really what we've got
here and a recommendation which um I
don't know if you want to put the
recommendation chair well before I do
that I just want to sort of add to that
and I mean I was a member on this
committee last year and not a member of
the working group and I found the fact
very disengaging uh and
um things are going on which I wasn't
aware of and then they used to report
and I didn't so I I fully well as I say
I fully support this move and therefore
put it to you that as a recommendation
that the the working group be the
committee I mean obviously not everyone
will be able to turn up each time but
obviously the more the merrier is that
is that agreed
good excellent
pretty quick right
um moving on to uh agenda item seven uh
appointment of Representatives to
outside bodies
[Music]
introduce this to us Mr Jenny uh well
simply to say this this is a standing
annual appointment on the council's list
and it falls to this community
um to a point of Representative to serve
on
um
the county council's health overview
committee and we have circulated details
of the meetings from the County
council's website and there are links to
the various meetings to see what the
nature of the business is and
um as I say it is an annual appointment
as a district representative on a county
scrutiny committee
do do we have any volunteers to do it
has anyone anyone they wish to nominate
sorry
as we had a volunteer earlier I would
like to nominate councilor Stevens all
right one moment was that this one
you've got the wrong one yeah
no no hold it hold it
could have done it fine do we have any
nominations
do you want to
right
well it will be I'm afraid yes yes I'm
pretty certainly
well done here
excellent so that we can't suspensely
excellent right uh good and now we come
to the next item which is uh item eight
or point two member Representatives
support the work on the process
Improvement committee a proven framework
rather and here indeed we do have one
volunteer Council Stevens has agreed to
continue
um could you just perhaps outline to
everybody exactly what this entails just
a sort of perhaps attract someone else
to uh to join you I don't know if I can
attract somebody else to joined it
actually
um the group has
seen through some improvements but I
would like to try and make some
improvements to the way that the group
operates because I found it
the methodology quite dense and hard to
get my head round maybe that says more
about me than the methodology I don't
know
um lots of matrixes and things and I
just thought well we could just have a
list of things that need improving and
tick them off that's how I would do it I
mean I get that you might want to
prioritize things and so there would be
that level of complexity
I also think that perhaps we were
looking a little bit at some processes
that
and procedures that the public don't
really see the procedure they'll see the
outcome at the end but they don't see
the procedure and we as members don't
either so I think if the council
officers want to improve those
absolutely they they should but I don't
think we need to be involved with that
so I'd like to move the group round a
little bit more to be more focused on
the outcomes for residents and looking
at what happens here for the resident is
that good no it's not so let's improve
it and do it from that end so I can't
thoroughly recommend my experience on
the group to date but I think they're
still the scope for it to be a good
thing let's put it like that
does anyone want to
in which case I'll follow my soul as
well
right uh Now we move on to uh item nine
reference from the performance
government audits committee with regards
to the review of the management process
associated with the splash park at
Promenade Park more than dude
not really Chan it's purely for this
meeting to receive formally receive the
reference and decide what
what to do with it um the normal process
is for it to
um go to the working group
um
with a request for more information to
so that members have an understanding
what the issues are and then
um one of two things basically Can Can
Happen the working group can say well
in understanding and and setting out the
issues this may be a watching brief item
or it can recommend back to the
committee that should be added to its
work plan and what the remit of that
work plan uh scrutiny should be and help
help plan that out
um I would just add by way of
information that it's my understanding
and I've just looked it up actually it
was also
um a decision of
uh performance governance and audit
committee at the same meeting that the
business model and costs of the splash
park
um be mapped out reviewed and reported
back to a future meeting of the strategy
and resources committee for member
decision on the way forward and I
understand that is to be done in the
context of next year's budget so there
is a report on The Wider impacts and and
considerations of the business model and
costs still to come through committee
okay Council lager would be delighted to
see you here is this something you would
like to speak about yeah thank you
chairman yes you're quite correct I was
I'm not on this committee so thank you
for letting me speak
um this came to my attention with the
substantial number of contacts from
residents about the splash park and it
not be an open ring council had resolved
that it should be open
was then closed for some essential
maintenance
after it had been closed for many months
for maintenance so this is why I started
to get interested on the why
why in that in that window of
opportunity did the council and the
teams involved and the contractors that
are chosen to run it
not have a sufficient plan a management
plan to be able to do all the
maintenance in in expedient time to open
it up for the summer so that was the
main driver
and also I felt very strongly that
because what I and I use the word
mismanagement of process there
um in that meeting which I still
maintain uh is is very sound that the
operating model of a splash park of a
district asset being open for four hours
on a Saturday and four hours on a Sunday
misses a massive opportunity for us to
gain our a greater amount of income
provide the asset for uh people with
special needs disabilities sends uh
preschool children so if we open it up
more we could actually leverage the
asset to give us more and what we all
know as members as incredibly
challenging times so that was the the
background as why I I came and spoke and
I was very pleased when the PG a
committee took the decision to accept
that and then very pleased to see that
it's come to this committee and may also
commend the chair and the vice chair and
all members it's so empowering to see
people go oh yes we need to work
together on things rather than have a
tiny segment of members make a decision
on something come to other members who
won't have a clue how that decision was
made it certainly breeds a deal of
inclusiveness and helps build the the
bridges that were missing in the last
agenda so chair there that's our members
that's why why I came this evening but
very stupid by the chair and that's why
I um pushed it and I'm passionate to see
this this Venture work better thank you
okay so yes councilman yeah I just
wonder what I actually I essentially the
main issues
um with it or the stumbling blocks
really what's been is it one single
thing or is it just a multitude of
reasons
a little bit
but I have been going every day and
watching kids enjoy it immensely
um uh two areas and it's very easy to
sit on the outside and criticize in when
you don't know all the facts
um but there's a reason because of the
cost of electricity because of the cost
of water
um the pumps were running consistently
so it was a decision made to put a more
uh efficient pumping system in there and
a long Milton being very very beautiful
Town alongside of a river obviously has
rabbits and seagulls that do their
business on the surface so there's a UV
lighting system that needed to be
installed
um but that would have been known a long
time ago so I just think there's a
there's a disconnect against the Morley
from when you when you do a project plan
your project plan you get it you know
what your Milestones are
the the back end of that
um could have been brought in when all
the other maintenance work was done so
my question for that is why and then
we've got to look at the model about how
we maximize income from that and have
the asset actually open for the people
of the district and those who want to
come in and use it oh that explains a
little bit more
yeah I'm quite interested I'd like to
know more about that I like that sort of
practical side of things and and the
reasons why
um yeah you said about the cost of does
it have to be heated
and to my understanding no
um but the water is the water isn't this
Affiliated it's been a long day
um filtered I knew not to like toolsbury
to do then I've used to swim in there
for kids just pump seawater in
not in this day and age unfortunately uh
yeah but not not down with that type of
equipment with the pumping systems and
the filtration systems I think seawater
through those pumps would be we would
kill the pumps we had a we had a
wonderful swimming pool in Malden but we
won't go into that topic now because
that's not they use pumps for sea water
in ships and Things No
pumps aren't the issue I would have
thought lovely salty water's perfect but
yeah
um so I was just going to ask Mr
Jennings how
um the report that's coming forward to
SNR will impact how we should treat this
with opium scrutiny where you know I'm
obviously aware of the fact that we
don't want to ask officers for multiple
different reports so would it be best
for us to take if we if the committee so
wishes to adopt this into the working
group as a watching brief wait for the
report to come forward and then possibly
depending on that report and the
discussion in the working group then
take it forward as a full work plan item
if that's the desire of the members to
do so at that point
German that's certainly a course of
action you can take
um first thing is to receive the
reference obviously and
um point it towards the working group
whichever way it goes it will be on the
list of items to pick up at the working
group and
um we will supply we will speak to the
relevant officers and get some
information to members to have a greater
understanding of what those issues are
as between the processes you've you've
heard about from councilor Lagan and the
the operational decisions and The Wider
context of the business model so you can
decide between the two elements really
okay thanks so um so members the The
Proposal is that we accept the reference
from PG Lane add it to our scrutiny from
the working groups and the work plan and
keep a watching brief as Pro and
progress can then be reviewed as it
proceeds to save it in all agreed
good
okay so moving on to item 10 any other
items of business chairperson of the
committee decides are Urgent and I have
none
therefore
I think members thank you for your
contributions this evening I now draw
the meeting to a close at 801 thank you